- Decisions based on
accounting considerations
can destroy company value.
In this video I will show you
why you need to understand
the basics of accounting
in order to be successful in your career.
Hi everyone, my name is Heinrich,
and welcome to another
episode of Firm Learning.
Thank you very much for watching.
If you haven't yet, please
subscribe to the channel below,
and press the like button
if you take any value
out of this video at all.
Accounting is something that many people
consider boring,
and I've seen even many business students
not taking a large
interest into accounting,
or even completing a
business studies degree,
or business administration degree,
and not really having understood
the basics of accounting,
even though they had some
kind of lectures in it.
In my opinion, this is a problem.
And from my experience of having worked
several years in a large
strategy consulting firm,
I can assure you that
is absolutely necessary
for your career that you know
the basics of accounting.
And the reason is that in
business, on a managerial level,
many decisions need to be made
in which accounting plays a role.
Managers actually take decisions
due to accounting considerations.
And this can often lead to decisions
that actually destroy company
value just for the reason that
it might positively affect
some accounting figures.
So in order to take part
in these discussions
you need to understand these
accounting considerations
so that you understand your colleagues
if they want to go a certain path,
which might not be driven
by financial value,
but might be driven by an
accounting consideration.
And this is not to say that these people
make these decisions
because they are irrational,
or because they don't
know what they are doing,
they have very good reasons
why they choose certain actions
which might destroy firm
value just due to accounting,
because of course accounting matters.
If a company publishes accounting figures
which aren't up to the expectations,
there can be some real consequences.
Frequently the compensation of managers
is closely tied to accounting figures.
And these things are real,
companies can overvalue these things,
over actual financial
value of the company.
And it is just crucial that
you understand these trade-offs
in order to be considered
a competent member
in the management group
that you are a part of.
In this video I will give you
two tangible examples of situations,
how accounting can distort
managerial decision makers.
These are two stylized
situations that actually
you see pretty frequently
happening out there.
These things are not just
theoretical examples,
but really happen all the time,
I can tell you this from my experience
in having worked in several industries.
So it's really crucial that
you understand these examples,
but make no mistake, there are
many, many other situations.
Many, many other accounting driven reasons
where companies might take a certain route
which might improve
certain short term figures,
but actually to value
destruction on a financial level.
So let's jump into it.
So the first topic is the distinction
between OPEX and CAPEX.
So just the preliminary remark,
this video cannot serve as
a full accounting primer,
but I'll try to explain
some basic concepts
just as a refresher.
But if you're completely
new to accounting,
if you did not have any
training in this topic at all,
please look out for some
more basic resources.
This video will assume that you at least
have a basic understanding
of how accounting works.
So the first example of what kind
of accounting considerations
can actually destroy
a company value, is the
distinction between OPEX and CAPEX.
So, OPEX and CAPEX, what is this?
Here I have the definition of Wikipedia.
OPEX stands for Operating Expenditure.
It's defined as an
ongoing cost for running
a product, business, or system.
So this is just the regular
cost that companies have.
So you can consider, for
instance, personal costs here.
You can consider here costs
for service providers,
for rent that you need to pay
for the facilities that you run,
for utilities, for all
these kinds of things,
for business supplies,
just the other costs
of just running a business,
of running a product.
So this is considered OPEX,
operating expenditure.
And OPEX is often contrasted by CAPEX.
CAPEX stands for a capital expenditure,
and it is defined as
the cost of developing
or providing non-consumable
parts for the product or system.
And here are some examples,
this is something that
you would usually consider
an investment, an investment to something.
So for instance buying a machine,
that then you use to produce products.
Buying a building, buying some land,
that you use to build a factory.
So things where you invest a
certain amount of money today,
for which you hope that
you will get returns.
So that you will hope to get
some useful value out of it
in the future, over a
longer period of time.
So why does this matter?
How is this distinction at
all relevant to managers
making decisions for their companies.
Let's look into how OPEX
and CAPEX expenditures
affect the income statement
and the balance statement.
And for starters, in one dimension of cost
they're completely the same in the sense
that you need to pay now, right?
From a cash flow perspective,
it does not make any difference
if you have an OPEX expenditure,
or a CAPEX expenditure, right?
So if you pay for CAPEX or for OPEX,
you need to pay now.
So this doesn't have to do anything here,
this is the same for both.
But there are differences when it comes
to the income statement,
and the balance sheet.
And now let's look at the two.
OPEX operating expenditure
directly goes into the income statement,
into the profit and loss statement.
So if you spend a certain amount of money,
for instance, for your
personnel, for you employees,
then you will put that an as expense
in your income statement,
in the exact year that
the expense has occurred.
And the implication of that is that
if you will pay now, for instance,
€100, $100 to pay your personnel,
or to buy office equipment,
or on other expenditures
which are considered OPEX,
then the profit, the earnings before tax,
or then the net profit in the very end
that you will need to report,
will be reduced by the exact amount
of the expenditure that you had.
So OPEX is directly affecting
your income statement,
your P&L, if you spent a dollar in OPEX,
your profit is directly in that same year
reduced by the same dollar.
And this is why managers
often do not like OPEX,
because it directly
reduces their net profit.
It directly has a negative
impact on their P&L, right?
So let's now contrast that with CAPEX
with an expense that you can
book as capital expenditure.
So again, from a cash flow
perspective, that's the same,
you need to pay directly right now
all the money leaves your bank account.
But the difference is that it does not
directly go through your income statement,
because it first gets
into your balance sheet.
So let's imagine now for
€400 or €100 million,
or whatever the amount
may be, you buy a machine.
Now, in your assets on the balance sheet,
there will be a machine appearing
with the book value of
€100 million or dollar,
but it does not directly
go to the income statement.
So you do not have to
directly book an expense
of 100 million in your income statement.
So what happens instead,
if you incur a CAPEX expense,
there is a depreciation schedule.
So there's decided that each year
over a certain defined amount of years,
a certain portion of the CAPEX
expense that you incurred
will go to the income
statement as depreciation.
So, if you have now this
machine of worth 100 million,
there might be maybe a 20 year
or a 50 year depreciation period.
So, if now you have a 20
year depreciation period,
this means that each year for 20 years,
you will pay €5 million
or dollar as depreciation
in your income statement.
So, instead of taking the
direct hit of 100 right now,
in this year, you suddenly
only need to show five
as the depreciation in this year.
And of course, this has a much better
much more favorable net profit effect,
especially in the short term.
So what happens the next,
then of course, the asset in the next year
gets reduced by the depreciation.
So if you depreciate it by 5 million,
then instead of 100 on your balance sheet,
it will only show five, next year,
and so on and so forth.
So again, what does
this mean for managers?
And the truth is that
even though of course,
there are accounting rules which prevent
you to freely choosing from,
whether you book something
as OPEX or CAPEX.
In reality, you often have
some degrees of freedom,
whether you book something
as OPEX or CAPEX.
So here you could be in a
situation where you decide
how you book something,
or maybe you have to choose
between two projects,
and the one project you can
book and expense as OPEX
and then the other project
you can book as an expense as CAPEX.
So, let's look now over
a longer period of time,
how the decision whether
you have an OPEX or CAPEX expenditure,
actually affects your income statement.
So the first option is OPEX.
Let's imagine our company that earns
for a period of 10 years, revenues of 50,
and in order to earn these revenues of 50,
they need to incur an OPEX expense of 100.
And let's imagine just for
the sake of the argument
that there are no other
expenses in this company.
So this would lead to the
situation in the first year,
you would show a profit of minus 50.
And then in the next years,
you would show a profit of plus 50
because the OPEX directly
gets P&L effective
in the very first year
and actually incurs,
and then you do not need to book it again
in the next years after.
So if you sum this up,
you get to a situation
where after 10 years,
you will have made revenues of 500.
So 10 times 15,
you will have OPEX expenses of 100
and therefore a total profit of 400.
So let's contrast that with the scenario
where you have a very similar situation,
but instead of booking
the same expenses as OPEX,
you are actually able to book it as CAPEX,
and now the situation
looks a bit different
in the sense that, in the first year,
if you assume that the
CAPEX gets depreciated
over the full 10 year lifespan
of this project of this company,
you only need to pay 10 every year.
It's 100 divided by 10,
so the result is 10.
And the result now is
that at the same revenues,
depreciation 10 in the very first year,
instead of needing to
show a profit of minus 50,
you can now show a profit of plus 40.
But then of course, the downside is that
in the next years, you have
the same depreciation amounts,
so we already showed the 40 as a profit.
And as you can imagine,
many managers will highly
benefit the situation
of the CAPEX investment
over the situation of the OPEX investment,
because they do not want
to show a loss of 50
in the first year.
And there's many also empirical
studies that investors
dislike lots of uncertainty,
what the earnings of a company are.
So it's often considered favorably,
if you can smoothen out
the earnings over time,
compared to having a situation
where you have high jumps
and suddenly being significantly negative
in the earnings of the company.
Of course, the second effect is that
the compensation of managers
is often tied to the earnings.
And you can imagine that
the personal compensation
of a manager alone, it's
significantly better
if the company shows a profit
of 40, compared to minus 50.
And people tend to discount the future
in favor of the short term.
Maybe also, because this
person only plans to stay
at the company for a
certain amount of years,
which is why CAPEX investments
often gets favored.
And of course,
if you add all of this up
over the 10 year time period,
you see that the revenues
are exactly the same.
The expenses are in the
long run exactly the same
not only that, it's booked as
depreciation instead of OPEX.
And the profit is exactly the same.
But you will see that managers
favor CAPEX investment
for the OPEX expenditure
for these reasons.
So why can this destroy
financial value for the company?
Well imagine that now
you would have project
with the payoff profile of this option one
in front of you as a manager,
and you would be able to
earn revenues of in total 500
over a 10 year period, by
investing once, OPEX 100.
Of course, on the financial
value perspective,
it would be beneficial for the company
to undergo this investment project.
But now if you would be strongly
incentivized as a manager
for the short term,
or maybe you are in a bit of
a tough financial situation
with the company.
You are under financial distress,
you may be in a restructuring process
and have committed to
certain profit numbers
to your external stakeholders
and to investors.
You might decide to
not do this option one,
even though it would make
financial sense for the company
due to the short term negative effects
in your books in your
accounting statements
that this project might have.
So now let's look into a
second type of examples.
And the second type of situations
that I've seen many times occur,
especially in a retail context,
but other industries as well.
And this is the effect of
which depreciation schedule
exactly you have on your
inventory, on your assets,
and how that depreciation
schedule might affect
your decision to sell or not to sell
certain products in the future.
So let's think about
the following scenario.
You are a buyer of a retail company
let's say you are a fashion
and apparel company,
and you go out there and you buy 50 units
of certain merchandise.
And you know that you can
sell the units in this year
at a retail price of five euro per unit,
you know that this is the fair
market price of these pieces.
And now you're able to buy
these at a value of two.
So sounds like good deal, right?
You can sell it at five and buy it two.
So now what does the balance sheet
at the beginning of this year look like?
You have an inventory of
100 in the balance sheet
because you bought 50 units
at a book value, at a
purchase price of two.
So let's just assume for simplicity
that purchase price equals the book value.
And now you go out there
in the marketplace,
and you start now to sell these things.
And in the first year,
you achieve to say 20
units of the 50 units
that you initially purchase.
And this for an apparent
for retail company
is nothing too unusual
so you often buy a
certain amount of stock,
and then of course, you try
to sell as much as possible
as fast as possible,
but after the season of course
often you have some stocks left over,
then you need to sell
again in the next season.
And because you know that
you get a retail value
of five per unit,
these 20 units now in
your income statement
lead to a revenue of 100.
Now, if you look into the cost,
let's now go into the income statement
for these 100 revenues that you made.
This is the cost of goods sold.
This is now a cost of 40.
Why 40?
Because here now you need to
look at the book value, right?
You sell 20 units,
these units are in your book
at a purchase price of two
so book value of two per unit.
So two times 20 is 40.
So you need to book costs
of goods sold of €40,
and this then would
lead to a profit of 60.
So 100 minus 40.
So what is now the situation in year two?
Now you have 30 units left in stock,
because you already
sold 20 of the 50 units
that you initially have.
And now of course the retail
value of these units decreased
because usually the longer you wait
and the older your merchandise is,
the price that you actually
get for the merchandise
is smaller and smaller.
And again, you think
about a fashion company
this is very much true.
In the next season, you will
usually only be able to sell
the pieces of last season
at a significant discount.
So let's now imagine for
this calculator example
that instead of getting
five, you can only get three.
Now let's look into the inventory.
And here know it gets interesting.
Because in this example
now the company decided
to not depreciate the inventory
that they have, right?
So they still decided to keep a book value
of two per unit on the inventory.
And why would they do that?
Well, if they do decide to depreciate
the inventory that they have,
then they would need to
show a depreciation expense
here in the last year
in the income statement,
in the same height that
they actually depreciate
the inventory that's left over.
And of course,
for the reasons that we've
seen in the last example,
the company usually has an incentive
to depreciate as slowly as possible.
Because the faster you depreciate,
the quicker the expenses show
up in your income statement
and as said, you usually
want to delay the expenses
to hit your income statement
as long as possible,
in order to show a positive
result for your company
that is as high as possible.
And again companies usually
have some degrees of discretion,
some degrees of freedom to what extent
they depreciate the merchandise.
And here now in this of
course, a bit extreme example,
we will be in a situation
where they do not depreciate at all
and you would still keep the merchandise,
those 30 units of stock
at the book value of two
with the inventory of 60.
So because now it's
already the next season,
you cannot sell as much
of it as the last season.
Because usually now you will
already have new merchandise in
which of course try to
sell it with a focus,
but you still manage now to sell 10 units
of this overload of inventory.
So 10 units at a retail value of three
leads to revenues of 30.
And for these 10 units,
now you need to book
€20 of cost of goods sold,
because they're still in your
books at two euro per unit.
So 10 times two is 20.
Now you would at least
then show profit of 10.
So let's now look into the next year.
Now you still have 20 units left in stock.
And the retail value of these 20 units
though keeps of course
decreasing every year,
and now is only at two euro.
Now what does the inventory look like
you still did not take
any depreciation expense
because you try to delay
that as much as possible.
And now you're 20 units that
you still have an inventory
of €40 because they bought
that two euro per unit.
And if you now again managed
to sell 10 units of the stock,
you have no revenues of
20 because 10 times two,
but now you also need to book
cost of goods sold at of two,
and this then leads to profit of zero.
Now of course the whole
situation doesn't seem
that positive anymore.
And you seem to ask,
why do I even keep bothering selling this
if it doesn't give me any profit.
And now, of course, when
it really gets unpleasant,
is not if you think this
is one year further,
you stood up the 10 units left,
they are now only at a retail rate of one.
So you can only get one euro for it
because it's not really old merchandise,
probably already looks a bit old
and not as fresh anymore,
and you will only be able to sell it
at a significant discount.
But unfortunately, you still have
these 10 pieces in your
books at a value of two,
because you just did not
want to depreciate it,
because then you would
have taken these sets
in your P&L, in your income
statement much earlier.
And if you now even would
have the opportunity
to sell these 10 units
at the retail value,
then you would have to
book revenues of 10.
But your cost of goods
sold would still be 20.
And then you would report
a loss for the sale of 10.
And this is now where managerial decisions
really can come into play.
And this will be a situation
where some companies
will prefer to not sell
this inventory at all,
they will prefer to just keep it somewhere
in your stock to let it rot away,
but not sell it because if you sell it,
you would report a loss of 10.
And you do not want a negative result
in your income statement,
because the company might
already be stretched,
because the company
might already fear that
it will not reach the yearly targets.
So they rather don't take the sale at all,
instead of needing to take the hit
of taking a negative loss of 10.
And this happens, believe me,
I've seen things like
that very, very frequently
in the corporate world.
People do not want negative
resides on the income statement,
and they would rather
decide to just let it rot
instead of taking the loss of 10.
And of course, this is now a situation
where you really destroy company value.
Because even though of course,
you would report a loss of
10 in your income statement,
you would at least still get the money,
you would at least still
be able to get your €10
for the merchandise.
But if you do not sell it,
and let it just stay in your
stock pretty much forever,
then the situation is that
you will never say this.
And of course, if you
know wait even longer,
if you wait even more
years, then at some point,
you will not be able to sell it at all
or maybe not at a value
of one euro per unit,
maybe only at ¢10 per unit.
So you would have the opportunity
to now get €10 for it,
but you do not sell it because
you do not want the income statement loss,
even though your company
would be better off,
your company's financial value
would increase if you sell it.
So this is managerial decision
making driven by accounting
that really leads to destruction
of company value or firm value.
And this happens, things like that happen
frequently in the corporate world,
if you do not understand these
accounting considerations,
you cannot take part in
these managerial discussions.
So these were the two examples
that I wanted to show you.
And the reason again,
why I'm showing you this
is because I want to
stress how important it is
that you have at least
a basic understanding
of these kind of
accounting considerations,
even with business graduates
are often get the feeling
that many believe that as a manager,
they will make the important decisions,
they will think about
what's best for the company.
And then there are some
bookkeepers somewhere
to just take care of the books
and we'll just make sure
that some of all of this
gets translated in the correct way.
But I can tell you this
is a clear misconception.
On the sea level, large
blue chip companies,
you can be sure that the senior
leaders of these companies
have a very good understanding of what
the accounting implications are
of the decisions that they take.
And these things are very much
top of mind for these companies.
And if you just enter a discussion,
just ignoring these
accounting implementations,
you will look like a fool,
you will look like you do not understand
what matters to these
sea level executives.
So make sure that you get
some accounting basics.
In my university studies,
there was one book
which I found really useful
in learning exactly these
basics of accounting,
I left the link to the book
below in the description.
To be fair, it's a bit expensive,
but I can tell you it's really worth it.
I bought it myself when I was a student.
So if you would like a basic primer
into how accounting works,
it's really easy to understand,
it goes into some level of detail.
And I promise you that
your level of understanding
will be much higher than
that of most of people.
And it's also written
in a fairly easy to understand language.
So even a few so far did not have
much exposure of accounting,
this will help you.
So thank you again for watching.
I hope you took some
value out of this video.
If you did, please press the like button,
and subscribe to the channel
to see more videos like that.
I will at least post one video every week.
Please also press the notification bell
to keep notifications whenever
I bring out a new channel.
Thank you for watching I'm
Heinrich from Firm Learning